what personality does a narcissist have
okay
so grandiose narcissism people who are
sort of have a sense of entitlement
they're self-centered they might think
they're better than other people but
they're also driven assertive
extroverted carismatic these are people
we end up in relationships with we end
up voting for them we work for them and
then we kind of like them and then we
kind of hate him too it's complex you
know people always like how do you tell
who's a narcissist who's a bad person
hard to know if I meet somebody really
narcissistic I usually walk away going
and I really like that person what you
see in the research is that people who
are narcissistic sort of know it but
with borderline you end up feeling gasl
sometimes I love you I hate you like
what did I do well nothing the person
changed gaslighting and you make people
insane because they can't test reality
effectively and then they can manipulate
you and exploit you when I was little I
thought that everybody was good and then
I came across a couple people that lied
about everything it's like are they a
witch what's happening they're not like
you you look around the room you care
about these people they don't like they
will do bad things and that doesn't
bother them and you can't believe that
because you can't believe anyone can do
that and when I get vibes like that I
start thinking psychopathy so what is it
that narcissistic people want what are
they looking for yeah that's a real
issue okay Keith let's start off can you
give a very brief background about who
you are and what you do and then I have
like more questions than we can possibly
get to okay so uh Keith Campbell I'm a
professor of psychology at the
University of Georgia in Athens Georgia
which is a well known for college
football and not so much psychology but
it's where I am I've
studied um let's see I did my my
undergrad at Berkeley I studied at
finished up in Social personality
psychology at Chapel Hill I did a post
talk with a guy named Roy bow Meister my
adviser was Constantine sedus if you
want to know the Deep background and
I've been an academic for about 23 years
in the field studying primarily
narcissism and sort of issues around the
self so I'm not a I'm not a clinician
I'm not a clinical psychologist I'm a
psychological researcher uh and I work
with some clinical researchers but my
focus is research
so why did you specialize in
narcissism couple reasons it was um well
I'll tell you the true story because one
of my friends asked me last night it's
really curious and the real story I was
in uh University of Madison or
University of Wisconsin Madison and we
were studying a process called the
self-serving bias which is this basic uh
phenomenon you see with people is we
like to take credit for success and
blame other people for failure so like
if my students get an A on exam they're
like man I'm smart and if they get an F
they're like Dr Campbell you've made it
too hard like yeah and that's that's a
useful thing because it keeps us feeling
positive about ourselves but I was
curious if everyone did that especially
in close relationships because what
happens in close relationships I'm with
my wife and Keith you did that I'm like
no my wife did I'm like that's going to
mess up my relationship so what I learn
is it's like Keith your wife did that
I'm like no I did it blame me don't my
wife and my you know and so I I Chang
things so this the selfishness that
self-serving bias changes when you
become you get in close relationships
because you care about the other person
and yourself sort of expands to
andcompany or Encompass that individual
and so I was interested in this question
I'm a young grad student and so we went
out to Ye Old pancake shop in Madison
with Constantine and Glenn reader and
remember Glenn saying hey we should look
at narcissism with this and I was kind
of a closet Freudian back in the day and
so I was like narcissism I love Freud
let's do it man and so that's why that
was kind of how it started was really
trying to understand how people differ
on this sort of self-enhancement
processes these sort of basic
self-processes and then I was always
interested in Buddhism and and sort of
more this spiritual idea of what is the
nonself what is
nonattachment uh you know not being ego
attached and I could never figure out
how to study that so it's sort of like I
studied the big ego to figure out what
egolessness was because it's
narcissistic when you watch people are
narcissistic you can watch them it's
very easy to see the ego it's like hey
look at me and people like look at you
and you're like I feel good my ego is
great and you see those Dynamics because
with these big personalities it's easy
to study and so I thought well I'll
study ego and narcissist and that'll
help me figure out ego but my goal
wasn't to be a narcissist or treat
narcissism it was sort of more like what
is the ego and how can we learn to kind
of let that go a little bit to be more
connected hey just to step in real quick
I have launched Afterparty for helping
break down a sealah hiide the toxic
byproduct of alcohol I don't want to
take up too much time because this
episode was sweet in my opinion so just
give it a shot there's a 30-day money
back guarantee if you don't like it free
shipping in the US it's pure third-party
test did highd dihydro myisis in with no
fillers I swear these will make you more
productive following drinking if you do
drink even a little it's not good for
your brain it's not good for you these
make a massive difference if you are
someone who is still going to have the
occasional vodka soda like me they
reduce nausea actual alcohol damage
headaches and leave you with this nice
calm chill feeling it's really
impressive try them let me know what you
guys think in the reviews check out
Fuller health.com Cod MP for 15% off
linked in the comments enjoy the rest of
this
episode so I I thought we should start
off by I like I'm interested in how
narcissism uh is shown in the Big Five
personality traits but I figured you
should explain briefly like what are the
Big Five personality traits before we
get into that yeah so this is a great
question so when we when we do
personality science and psychology of
Personality we use a couple different
models
more than a couple but there there are a
lot of very specific models of
Personality something like well
narcissism or typ a personality or
thrill seeking or grit so we talk about
these traits they're also what we call
General models of personality so these
are sort of bigger models that are
designed to capture the you know as much
as we can get of the entirety of
personality at
once and of those more General models of
personality the one that's over the last
20 30 years proven to be the more most
useful is What's called the big five now
there's nothing you know God didn't
stamp five things in our genes you know
it just these are things we agree on as
academics that work but five seems to
work pretty well and it turns out if you
take all the thousands of personality
traits out there imagine you had a
thousand traits you know creative kind
crazy cater Walling can
charitable compassion sorry I'm just
trying to think of CWS and you said hey
let's put him in buckets and we have
five big buckets out there and the ones
that are similar they go in the same
bucket well when you start doing that
process of throwing things in buckets
you get like five big buckets of traits
and those are the big five and they're
easy to remember because the first
letter spell ocean or canoe so we
usually spell ocean because people like
oceans um so I'll go through through it
in that order so the big five traits uh
in the order of ocean would be number
one which is openness to experience
which has aspects of uh love of complex
ideas and philosophy but also an
appreciation of art poetry
Aesthetics um conscientiousness which is
a combination of sort of industrious
work ethic self-efficacy and the ability
to get stuff done along with
organization focus on detail Etc so it's
sort of a detailed oriented but also
industrious individual extraversion
which most people know of is the more so
this aspect of sociability likability
but there's also an aspect of
extraversion which is assertiveness has
to do with leadership or
dominance and then uh
agreeableness which is a combination of
sort of compassion caring and warmth but
also uh cooperativeness sort of
following rules getting along with
people people be nice and then uh
neuroticism and neuroticism has these
components of sort of more anxiety
depression and also volatility or
instability of the self neuroticism is
what we see with a lot of the disorders
like uh depression or
anxiety so you think about those big
five traits as sort of a a very broad
map of
personality but then when you talk about
a specific trait like narcissism you can
mix them together in different ways to
get these more complex traits which I
can do if you want me to keep going but
I'm chatting a lot yeah I know that that
was a perfect overview um I love
personality my dad taught me so much
about personality when I was a kid and I
think it was so useful and understanding
the differences between people um that
was a that was a perfect overview so
yeah what what personality does a
narcissist have yeah so here's what
happens with narcissism so the trait of
narcissism is is sort of made up of
these broader traits or can be described
with these big five traits when we talk
about the trait of
narcissism there's two different forms
we tend to focus on in the literature
one form the one most of your audience
is thinking about or familiar with is
what we call grandiose narcissism it's
people who are sort of have a sense of
entitlement they're self-centered they
might think they're better than other
people but they're also driven assertive
extroverted charismatic these are people
we up in relationships with we end up
voting for them we work for them and
then we kind of like them and then we
kind of hate them too it's complex you
know Tony Stark pick your politician
it's it's that
narcissism and then there's this more
vulnerable form which has that same kind
of core of self-centeredness and
entitlement and disagreeableness but
also has a more neuroticism more self
focus more concern more uncertainty
lower self esteem so the more vulnerable
narcissist presentation is like secretly
in their head like I'm better than
everybody else but they're kind of
sometimes you say basement narcissist or
covert or playing video games downstairs
yelling at people on the internet
because of all my hostility and no
because no one appreciates my genius so
there these two different faces of
narcissism the grandiose one we're
familiar with this more vulnerable form
which we don't which looks a lot like
anxiety and depression um unless you get
to know the people people clinically or
you maybe see their hostility come out
in other ways so those two forms of
narcissism have a little bit different
recipe with the big five so to make
grandiose narcissism what you do is you
take this core trait of agreeableness
but it's low agreeableness or what we
might call Trade
antagonism so low agreeableness so
people who are
disagreeable and they're
extroverted so they're they're energized
they're sort of disagreeable extroverts
which is really interesting so you have
somebody who's sort of selfish not to
end up caring about people but really
sociable energetic likable so they do
really well socially but they're also
kind of mean and they cause problems so
my favorite example of this lately has
been the Tiger King which I sometimes
call The Lion King but I don't know if
you saw that show on Netflix with the
Tiger King yeah I saw a bit of it yeah
okay so this pandemic stuff but there's
this guy and he's like I'm the Tiger
King and he has all these tigers and
he's probably kind of a bad dude you
know when you look at the show and I
don't know if he killed any he's not
he's kind of a sketchy guy but you like
the Tiger King why do you like the Tiger
King why do you let this guy say he's
the king of the tiger I it's rhetorical
I said it's that e extraversion he's
very energized he has a lot of positive
emotionality a lot of extroversion and
that draws people to him so like I love
the Tiger King man he blows stuff up
he's got that great energy that's that
combination is grandiose
narcissism and that's why it can be
dangerous because it's like weaponized
antagonism or energized
antagonism in the big five sense does
that make sense a little bit yeah yeah
that does make sense that's perfect are
there people who are low in
agreeableness uh so you call that
antagonism basically high in antagonism
but is that is it always the case that
some whose low in agreeableness is high
in antagonism well we we sort of use the
word antagonism for the opposite pole we
just use that term but antagonism itself
can have different flavors so you can
have some people that are emotionally
callous they don't feel a lot you can
have some people that are more mean
which is not classically narcissistic
it's more sort of emotionally like I'm
not that invested in warmth I'm sort of
more self-focused and the lack of
humility can be in there there so low
agreeableness in includes like low
humility so it's capturing like a sense
of superiority callousness lack of
emotional warmth lack of empathy all
those things go into the trait of
antagonism okay that makes sense do do
people who have so oh yes I'm assuming
like like high levels of extraversion
low levels of
agreeableness does that just make you
into a narcissist or are there like
societal factors like are does that just
make you into a a narcissist well
there's got to be some of those people
that still are like what if you're
really high in conscientiousness as well
yeah so sort of the the recipe with
narcissism or Prim the primary recipe
for grandiose narcissism is that high
extroversion low agreeableness I should
say for vulnerable narcissism what you
see is you see the low agreeableness and
also but you see high neuroticism so
sort of a neurotic disagreeable that's
what vulnerable narcissism is and that's
why people don't really like vulnerable
narcissists not that they they don't
like but they just they're not they
don't like them because they don't have
the extraversion there's they're sort of
insecure and
antagonistic so they can't hide it and
what they look like is they might
present themselves as a little more
depressive or maybe hostile and
depressed um but but they don't have the
extraversion to really make navigate
life effectively as well um so I you can
describe both those those aspects of
narcissism with the traits but they're a
little more than that so you might see a
little you know with with grandio
narcissism you might see a little bit
more a little bit of openness
conscientious might be a little high
they might report a little elevated
which is weird because you might think
low uh with with vulnerable and with
Psychopaths and um trying to think what
else I don't I don't know what I missed
but I probably missed one in there yeah
so you can describe them differently the
other way to think about it is this is
sort of the foundational traits underly
these expressions of
narcissism but they get expressed
through specific social dynamics so
grandio
narcissism what you need to do is you
need to use the world to boost your ego
like if I I would say like if I think
I'm a 10 but I'm really a seven how do I
go through life feeling I'm a 10 well I
can dress up really well and I can I can
make myself so I can groom to make
myself into an eight and then I can get
a lot of power and money so people kind
of attracted to that and then I can
surround myself with people who tell me
I'm great and I can build a little posy
around myself build my kind of a
identity bubble that keeps me feeling
good and when there's a chance to jump
on a podcast with you I can jump on the
podcast hey look at me I'm great you
know I can go be popular I can I can dra
draw attention to myself so I do a lot
of these self-regulatory strategies that
have to do with
narcissism to maintain that ego so
there's a trade aspect to it but there's
also an interpersonal Dynamic aspect of
narcissism as well are you able to make
narcissistic people one aware of their
narcissism into wanting to change or
does the low in agreeableness just they
don't want to
change it's a great question so the old
idea where that people who were
narcissistic weren't really aware of it
that they just were kind of blind to
this but what you see in the research is
that people who are narcissistic sort of
know it they might not use that term but
they might uh but they will say you know
I really want to be a leader I'd like to
look at myself in the mirror if I rule
the world there' be a much better place
people will believe whatever I I like
you know they'll they'll agree to a lot
of those
things and even you know even when you
look at psychopathy with things like you
know uh it's better to look out for
number one people are psychopaths like
yeah you should look out for number one
screw everybody else you guys are idiots
to care for about people so there is
there is some self-awareness with
narcissism they might not see the damage
it's doing but there is some
self-awareness and that's why our
self-report measures work like that's
funny you know if if people weren't
aware of it they'd be like I don't know
and we'd have to use we'd have to
instead of using self-report we'd have
to get their friends or peer reports
we'd have to get their parents reports
we'd have to get their wives or husbands
reports but instead we can use
self-report because people are kind of
aware of it um in terms of change the
challenge with narcissism isn't so much
the change it's the motivation to change
which I think you're kind of getting at
yeah is if you think you're really good
and when you fail it's usually somebody
else's fault because they're always kind
of messing with you and no one really
sees how brilliant you are God darn it
if they did you'd really be a winner and
you'd have your own podcast um you don't
you don't want to change you know what
you want to do is change all those
idiots around you who are bringing you
down and maybe if you just had a better
looking girlfriend and got a new car
people would really see how great you
are so the the CH it's hard to do the
change part and when you get into the
clinical and we're just talking about
traits but when you get into the more
clinical aspect of this and more
disordered aspect this is what you see
in Psychotherapy where Psychotherapy can
work for narcissistic personality
disorder but the challenge is keeping
people in therapy they just drop out
very quickly because it's that ego it's
like if you've built up a narrative
about how great you are and therapy
involves breaking that it pushes people
away which is which means if you want to
change something you got to go at a
different angle but that's another
question
yeah uh my dad's so i' I've done my dad
has a personality test online at
understand.com that gives you a
breakdown of your five you know
personality traits and the 10 aspects uh
and my personality which he's pointed
out many times I've got like everything
set up to be a narcissist except
agreeableness you know splits into what
is it compassion and politeness yeah and
my politeness is at zero
but my agreeable but my compassion's at
87 so I'm actually not that dis
disagreeable in total but he's been like
he you have to be careful CU you're set
up to be somebody who like likes status
and likes power and all these things but
I think one of the things that's helped
me maybe mitigate the ego part of that
is he also taught you're responsible for
everything that happens in your life
like even those things that you don't
really feel responsible for everything
in your life life is your responsibility
and so maybe there's a way to teach
people who are more prone to narcissism
that if they take Joo talks about this
with radical responsibility for
everything as long as you don't blame
other people for your problems you think
that's one way to mitigate this a
absolutely so uh so what you're talking
about is like with the big you know with
these personality traits you can take
the five and then you can divide divide
them each into two aspects which I know
your dad has done and uh ah calling D
young your dad's student's brilliant
personality guy I know Colin pretty well
but I know he's looked at those aspects
and they're really useful and and it and
one one of that breakdown is exactly
what you're talking about is the
agreeableness so you are like a lot of
academics like me where I'm generally
compassionate I want people to I want
people I love people I want people to be
loving yeah I don't really listen to
Authority like I have a little bit of a
challenge like if you tell me what to do
that's a little challenging for me if
you if you ask me nice I'm like hey I'm
your best friend but if you tell me what
to do
I um and I I don't yeah so that that
politeness piece I I don't have as much
and that's pretty common with a lot of
academics because your if your idea is
I've got to come up with something new
that means I got to break something old
so if you're in a creative career you're
always breaking stuff and creating stuff
and you got to be comfortable breaking
stuff but but also uh what your dad
saying about relationships is a buffer
or compassion is a buffer to narcissism
is dead on that's that is really why I
got in the topic was how do these close
relationships buffer egotism how do they
buffer
self-enhancement and when I talk about
this for with people I people like you
know a lot of parents like how do I make
my kids Nar narcissistic I'm like well I
don't know but I have to give him
something so I say
CPR and because it's memorable but
that's compassion passion and resp
responsibility so the third of those
things is you have to practice taking
responsibility for everything especially
negative stuff so when you screw up you
go yeah that was me screwed this one up
I'll do better next time and I think as
a practice that keeps your egoo out of
it you're not pointing fingers at people
you're just saying hey I'm responsible
I'm going to take care of this and when
you do when you do take responsibility
for failure you get a sting you're like
God I screwed that one up that kind of
hurt my ego but by taking responsibility
it shows I'm capable of action so I'm
learning that I have efficacy I'm
learning I have the capability to act
and it also makes people respect me
because I'm not one of those people who
blames people I'm somebody who takes
responsibility so it kind of it it in a
weird way taking responsibility for
failure actually helps you become a more
successful person and be seen as more
successful because you're willing to
take that responsibility and go and then
that and then obviously the compassion
piece is what you were talking about as
that aspect of agreeableness if you can
bring up that compassion and really care
about people your ego is always in check
because I'm not going to do something
hurts my kid just never going to happen
and so if you have people like that in
your life a marriage a relationship a
parent you respect a child you love that
keeps you grounded you know keeps you
from going out outside the outside the
ego lines um and then the third one I
add a little off topic but it's passion
and it's just one people don't think
about which is like people if you do
things that you love with a lot of
passion uh you lose your ego because you
you get involved you get in a flow State
you get excited and so it's almost like
an egolessness egoless state but
afterwards you kind of feel stronger
because you went through it and people
look like you because they love passion
people love to see passion you know they
love people who are stoked doing what
they're doing um so if you if you just
focus on being passionate you can get a
a lot of those ego needs met without
having the ego in a weird
way I like that okay so it's not it's
not necessarily a lost cause if you're
very extroverted and low and
agreeableness if you try to implement
this CPR can you even change sorry can
you can you actually get somebody who's
low in compassion to be more
compassionate don't they just really
care in the first really okay how you do
that yeah so uh um well let me
personality can change and what we found
the last 10 20 years of research
especially the last 10 is you can really
change personality not huge amounts but
you know you can move people around the
second thing is when you said lost cause
I would never say that personality is a
tradeoff all of our traits have pluses
and minuses if I were more of a jerk I
would be rich my wife my excuse me my ex
wife in my jerk life you know would have
half my money so I might not have as
much but I would have made a lot more
money you know so these things are
tradeoffs and so I wouldn't ever think
about it as a lost cause and in terms of
hey I want to increase my compassion
well there's techniques to do so one of
the classic ones people talk about are
like loving kindness meditations which I
think come out of some of the Tibetan
Buddhist Traditions which is you know
you start off how much you love your mom
and then you say and you expand that
love once you get to think about how
much you love your mom to you know maybe
your friend and then maybe from your
friend to a stranger and then maybe from
your stranger to somebody you don't
really like like I really love that you
know so you practice feeling love for
somebody you don't like which is a
challenge but I saw the dolly llama back
in the day talk about his great
gratitude to China for destroying Tibet
said I'm grateful to the Chinese for
destroying Tibet because if it didn't
happen we wouldn't have moved out and
now Tibetan Buddhism is spread around
the world ah and I sat
there and I thought he is a better man
than I am you know I'm still pissed was
even my country um so so that kind of
practice but but a lot of the practices
I think are literally just being
intentional about being a better person
so for
myself I I I like to get stuff done and
I drive and I I used to get incredibly
angry driving because like everybody's
an idiot the world's falling apart I'm
driving I'm like the world's falling
apart oh my god I'm an idiot I'm
screaming I'm
yelling and my heart's just pumping I'm
like my cardiologist is like he's just
buying my cardi is like buying a new G
wagon because he's like dude Kei gonna
need so many bypasses I'm GNA be just a
legend and I realized this isn't helping
me and I could and I was at yoga one day
and one of my yoga teachers go well
whenever your stress just say God wants
me to be slow I'm like well that's the
dumbest thing I ever heard but I'll try
it because it's whatever I'm doing it's
not working and so whenever I get
frustrated I start going well God wants
me to be slow I just started doing that
just a very very basic behavioral
intervention this is like just the basic
cognitive behavioral therapy I mean it
could have just said a rubber band or
something you know it worked just took a
few months of doing that and pretty soon
I became a not aggressive driver but
it's dedicated action and intention over
time towards a goal it's a practice you
know so you make it a practice to be a
nice person I'm GNA be a nice person to
people I'm G to just shake hands be nice
and you say I'm going to do that when
I'd fail hey that's okay you're never
perfect and I get get better so I I'm a
big believer and if you want to be a
different person just make an effort and
if you do that over time
because what happens is you you start
being in the case of nice you start
being nice to people and at first it's
not going to work because people aren't
going to believe it but after time
people are going to be nice back to you
and you're going to get reinforced for
it and you're going to C oh this being
nice to people helps people like me and
then you're going to get attacked
because you did something you got
cancelled you said the wrong thing you
know I won't even say it because I'll
get cancelled I don't want to do that
and then everyone attacks you but
because you're nice people like hey
don't kill Keith he's pretty nice guy
you know so you go oh I'm glad I was
nice to people it didn't seem to do any
good but they didn't want to attack me
you know before everyone used to want to
attack me now they they don't seem they
don't like to they will but you know so
I'm a big believer in change via just
intentional practice over time I think
we can do
it I like that I think I did something
similar um with situations that I I like
to like control as much as I can and I
think part of that is because I was
taught this like radical responsibility
I was like okay well if I'm responsible
for everything then I should be able to
change certain situations and there are
some situations you actually can't
change and you're not responsible for
but it's better to just air on the side
of you're responsible for everything and
so I started for these situations that
were just like okay I've tried
everything I can't really change it um I
like figured this is only the last
couple years really let go and it was
the it was the same kind of like God
wants me to be slow but more like you
know this is some sort of this is just
something that's happening and it and
it'll end and I didn't have to enforce
my control on it and that helped a lot
like that you're not necessarily in
control of everything even though things
are your responsibility it's like a
balancing act but that helped me I
really like that because I might have a
control issue or two myself and that
kind of more dowst process of just
standing back and lets things happen and
just not try to go in there and change
it and break it because a lot of times
you
can't yeah and then sometimes you
realize when you're not in there messing
with things they work out by
themselves yeah which is so you kind of
trust the process I never believed that
my mom was much more like hippie dippy H
it is what it is and I was always like
it never is what it is you can always do
something about something bad happening
but then The more I've kind of relaxed
on that while taking responsibility for
what I can The more I've realized like
sometimes things do work out you know
meddle around with them even if it takes
a while I have I have uh I have gotten
to that place too kicking and screaming
and sometimes I think about it in sort
of yian terms which is usually not what
I work but it's almost like moving from
thinking to intuition where in the yian
system instead of thinking and trying to
control and logic you go up to the
intuitive system and you just kind of
Let The Vibes happen and you
Vibe is that yeah I mean that kind of
makesense that's exactly that's exactly
it yeah and I think like taking after my
dad I never took that the intuition part
or feeling things out without being able
to logically explain them I never took
that seriously I was always like that's
my mom I don't know what she's doing and
I don't understand it at all but it
doesn't seem right um and then I don't
know the last couple years of like no
there's something to that if if you're
if you are intuitive and you can kind of
relax a little bit sometimes things work
out so that's a bit of a relief yeah I
was talking my sister's a h a
psychotherapist out in the Bay Area and
I was talking to her about this actually
today and she's like I get these Vibes I
said yeah I do too sometimes I said you
know if you look at a lot of the the the
writing on religious practice or you
know like I said y Young's writings on
this it seems like a natural progress
ression that if you you learn stuff you
practice eventually you kind of get this
ability to use your intuition
effectively you know you see it in the
in the yoga Sutra they talk about about
like cities or whatever um you see it in
Yong but I think that if you practice
thinking you realize there's a limit to
thinking because you can't really Define
everything the variable like we're
living in an incredibly complex world
and our as academics we we kind of cut
the world into a real small box and I go
I can figure out that box but dude
that's not the world that's the box you
made but the whole complicated thing
like maybe your your thinking part isn't
enough that's really useful at times but
you got to kind of use your and this is
again this is Young talking about your
intuition you need to recognize patterns
at a deep level and sort of start
navigating those patterns like swimming
through the patterns of life okay that's
cool I didn't know that that was young
i' I'd figured when I started kind of
tapping into that and realizing that
that was actually real I didn't even
know that was real um what did I what
did I know we don't teach it it's our
fault I mean I'm a personality right
yeah but yeah well it's also like it's
hard exp it's kind of It kind of sounds
woo yeah and I figured out like once I
started seeing patterns and realizing
that it was real um I thought intuition
was a recognition of patterns that you
couldn't logically explain and your
body's giving you these signals cuz
you've you've learned what the pattern
means but there's nothing logical going
on so sometimes it's just better to go
with that feeling especially if it's
strong than to try and figure out
because maybe there are too many
variables involved and you just can't
explain it to yourself but I had no like
no
idea it's very hard to predict complex
systems look at meteorologists or
economists or anyone else they're
terrible at it because it's hard it just
doesn't because our models don't they
break down with complexity very quickly
and
if you're in a complex world you have to
use a different kind of decision in in
the old days you know they go have
oracles and people like what kind why
would you have an oracle you're an idiot
well the dolly Lama went to an oracle or
the
Greeks went to an oracle um because in a
complex world you know that kind of work
the oracles you know think of the
Vikings like that show Vikings you go to
the Oracle the Oracle goes up to the
clouds he talks to the gods he goes down
to the underworld talks to the gods and
the Oracle gives you some kind of vague
information and that sort of Sparks your
intuition and that makes you go they're
doing that because how else do you make
a decision in an incredibly complex
environment with limited information
like well I got to find the guy with the
Vibes you know or the the woman with the
Vibes the vibe woman who's you know
sitting over a gas chamber in Deli and
I'll ask her what she thinks and she'll
go into trance and tell me something I
gotta run with that yeah it's very
interesting yeah it is interesting
interesting it's very interesting so if
the personality traits that can lead to
narcissism if they're low and
agreeableness um and high extroversion
are men more likely to be narcissistic
or do you see a pretty even split it it
yes but it also depends on the form of
narcissism so with grandiose narcissism
with the high extroversion low
agreeableness you see more men when it
gets to the clinical disorder or the
narcissistic personality disorder it's
about uh 75% men with the
diagnosis oh so meaning and so there's
two explanations for that one is if you
get a few more men on average when you
get to the extremes of the distribution
you're going to end up with a lot more
men it also could be that clinicians
tend to kind of bucket men as
narcissistic whereas they say a woman
with similar traits they might say oh
she's borderline or they might say she's
histrionic so they might use a little
different language so something like
histan ISM which is really the
extraversion this Diva like disorder
they might use that instead of
narcissism whereas the men they might
say it's more narcissistic so that could
be a reason too it's hard to know uh but
with vulnerable narcissism which has a
lot of neuroticism in it that seems to
be equal between men and women because
on average women are a little more Nar
little more neurotic than men men are a
little more ant antagonistic than women
so added up and with the vulnerable
narcissist you end up with about the
same okay even though we always think I
don't know I always think of men with
vulnerable narcissism in particular
because I think of some of the school
shootings and things um but equal it's
equal so you mentioned borderline what's
the difference between in personality
traits what's the difference between
borderline and narcissism ah it's a
great question a little complicated
borderline itself is the term borderline
uh originally meant the line or the
border between neurosis which is sort of
everyday unhappiness misery and
psychosis which is more extreme delusion
so the psychoanalyst said the borderline
between those that's why they call it
borderline it's not a good term for it
so that's what it means like you're
borderline psychotic but that's really
not what it is what it is it seems like
when I talk to people who do this work
really well is it at core it's it's
difficulties regulating emotions so it's
really loaded on trait neuroticism
primarily with this emotional
disregulation but you also see some
antagonism you also see some uh you also
see some a lot of neuroticism with some
antagonism and some low
conscientiousness and impulsivity you
know when you get behaviors like cutting
or things that you see with borderline
so it it's kind of a disordered but when
you look at it like a trait it looks
like narcissism but with more
neuroticism and L conscientiousness it's
kind of sometimes the clinicians almost
talk about it as like less well formed
narcissism like narcissism is when you
got it together and you have a well
structured defense mechanism and
borderlines when it's not quite as well
structured that's kind of the kernberg
cohut you know I sorry this is getting a
little wonky with old school
psychodynamic stuff um but at a trait
level it's that more neuroticism with
borderline uh lower
conscientiousness and probably
extraversion that sounds brutal yeah
borderline is a real hard thing because
um yeah because it's that emotional
disregulation and I remember working
with like I'm not a clinician just want
to say that but when I did work in
hospitals and with borderline uh
patients there's just so much because
people feel uh when they're out of
control emotionally or sometimes they
feel empty inside they can't connect
anything they want to feel something so
sometimes they they cut themselves you
know just to feel that pain which kind
of focuses the self makes them feel
real it's not it's a tough condition we
have some real good treatments for it
now because there's a lot you know it's
a you know so there are good you know
dialectic behavior therapy there's some
other good therapies for it to kind of
focus on but it's a hard
one my dad always said if if you meet
somebody borderline just run that was it
he he had no Solutions he was just like
just avoid that person it's a very it's
very hard because it you know the in the
movies it's you sometimes what they'll
show to show borderline is is what they
call split object relations how do I say
that I love you no I hate you so the
it's very hard to have an integr so
we're all kind of good and bad you know
we're all we've all got the shadow it's
you know we're all kind of a mess I try
to be a good PE person but do bad things
I yell at my kids sometimes I hate
myself for it and then I hate myself for
hating myself then I double hate myself
and then I'm praying you know I'm just a
mess so we all we all um we all we all
have these these challenges uh kind of
in life but but with borderline it's
just harder to control the
emotions and so I hate to say avoid
people like that but really it's harder
to have relationships with somebody who
has that emotional disregulation because
you end up feeling gasl sometimes I love
you I hate you like what did I do well
nothing the
changed so sometimes people say that
they definitely say with narcissism you
know if you're were somebody
narcissistic you know I was it's my my
line my dad said to my do my sister
which is you know get a U-Haul leave a
note that was his suggestion I put that
on a t-shirt um so you know it's
obviously there's you you people stay in
relationships with people with even
disorders because they're they're
committed they have children they want
want it to work they do the hard work at
therapy they bring it back together it
can work out great but it's a lot of
work okay so one more question about I
think kind of these topics I've met a
few people in my life when I when I was
little I thought that everybody was good
and I don't think that anymore but I
thought that everybody I met was kind of
the same as me not that I'm saying I'm
like good necessarily but I just put my
personality on everybody I met until I
was about 23 um and then I came across a
couple people I think I've come across
four people now um that lied about
everything and I mean like you a very
weird way they even recounting what
happened it wouldn't be quite true so
whatever reality they were living in
just wasn't real in my opinion and it
was everything and it made it very
difficult like Vibes were way off if
we're talking about Vibes vibes her way
off very like dangerous feeling
situation have you ever come across
people that just twist everything a
little bit and what is that about well
yes uh what you said before was exactly
right on so there was a psychiatrist
named last named Masterson in in
Manhattan back in the day who was a he
was the narcissism
Legend and when he used to talk about it
with people he'd say look
because you don't people who are
narcissistic just don't care I mean this
is at the extremes okay this sort of at
the extreme level they're not like you
you look around the room you care about
these people they don't like they will
do bad things and that doesn't bother
them and you can't believe that because
you can't believe anyone can do that and
I get I Get snookered By narcissists all
the time because I'm like I can't
believe you do I can believe you'd show
off get attention but when people do the
evil stuff
or the the massive deception or
dishonesty which has this little
psychopathy feel to it uh you go why are
you doing that like I don't even see the
upside to it you you know you got some
skills you don't even need to this is
insane um yes there are people like that
um you look at some cult leaders uh
there's a cult the N vixm cult remember
that where they branded the celebrities
and was a anyway I talked to one of the
guys in that cult and he was telling me
the same thing you just said about the
cult later like bad guy heard about
other people you know you think they're
good guys just bad guys so yeah that's a
real issue uh the term we use in the
narcissism world uh not in the world but
it kind of came up is
gaslighting so you end up with these
people and you feel like they're
distorting reality all the time and it
makes you feel
uncomfortable and so the term people
will use is hey your gas lighting me and
that I mean if people aren't familiar
with it comes it's a weird word because
it comes from an old movie which I think
was a play before that where a husband
was trying to mess with his wife make
her think she's going crazy so he' like
change the G put the gas lights down
she's like the gas lights are down he go
like no they're not honey are you going
crazy and they turn it back up and she
like they're messing like oh you're must
be you know so you know there's noises
in the attic I don't hear anything and
his friends up there pounding the door I
just made that one up that you make
people insane because they can't they
can't test reality effectively so people
when they feel detached from reality
they start to freak out very fast yeah
because we're always we're always dialed
in and when that reality connection
breaks that reality testing breaks um it
can make you very uncomfortable and they
do that they're kind of doing that to
break your hold on reality and then you
can't control yourself and then they can
manipulate you and exploit you so I'm a
cult leader I'm like I could start a
cult right I'm a I'm a extroverted guy
and I seem confident so I could start a
cult no problem I get people to come in
I'm nice at first and then what I do in
a cult is I start gaslighting them and
then that I start cutting them off from
their old friends and family because if
I'm gaslighting them they go to my go
back to their friend and the friend's
like dude Keith the call leader is a
jerk he's lying to you so I'm the call
leader I'm like no you got to stay with
me you got to hang out with the cult and
then the cult all talk to each other and
they take that gaslit narrative and
because they all agree on it it's it
turns from gaslighting into reality oh
because reality becomes socially
constructed right so then you have
everybody in the cult believing this
gaset reality and then if somebody
outside comes to threaten them they will
all attack that
person right because they they're
defending their belief
systems what I'm getting off Bas here
but what the heck you you guys are smart
you've got a smart audience so when
psychologists started looking at
something like this back in the day a
psychologist at Stanford who was
interested in in self-process he named
Leon festinger wrote a wrote a book
called when prophecy fails and maybe
people are familiar with this but he
wanted to study Cults this was back in
the 50s 60s and they weren't worried
about the cult leaders killing you or
anything people were nice he sent uh he
sent a student up to a cult near Chicago
I think it was like
Maran something I always think it's like
mayor from the planet clear like the
B-52 song that was before from be when
before you were born um and the cult
predicted the end of the world everyone
in the cult thought the world was going
to end on a certain day cult later said
it would world didn't end everyone in
the cult's like mad and the cult later
goes and goes and prays and comes back
and said hey good news guys I skipped a
couple chapters but good news guys the
world didn't end because God was so
impressed with you that he decided to
spare the world you're like the new Noah
and then people started believing that
they're like yeah that story is good
that this is the the root of cognitive
dissonance the dissonance would be I
gave myself up for a cult I'm an idiot
but the new story is I'm the smartest
person ever I gave myself up to the ult
and save the
world and then those people started
prizing so meaning they started going
out and telling other people hey join
our cult we just saved the world so they
started recruiting people into it so so
this
gaslighting at this extreme level seems
like it wouldn't work but if you can
control people enough and get three
people to believe the gaslit
story it it can become something like a
cult and become
self-reinforcing
that terrifying ABS freak litely
terrifying because you just watch the
world and it has been one big FES iner
experiment it's unreal yeah yeah I think
I understand that better after meeting a
couple people that really confused me
where it was just like I'm like dizzy
after talking to you like what what is
that about it's like are they a witch I
don't even believe in witches but like
what's happening right now during this
convers I don't understand what's going
on it's just the weirdest
experience and when I get vibes like
that I start thinking
psychopathy and you what is what is
psychopathy versus narcissism well
they're kind of this they're kind of
cousins you know I don't know but when I
think of that real exploitation real
manipulation real
intentional that real kind of
nefariousness you know a lot of
narcissism you know classic narcissism
is hey look at me I'm a big deal you
know and if people look at you and
you're big deal you're okay like you're
you're fine as long as you feel like
people think you're cool but when you're
out there really just systematically
breaking people and destroying them in a
malicious and intentional way it kind of
spills into psychopathy and even sadism
and yeah you get vibes like that just
get the heck out of there because you
don't need that in your life um and
people will sneak up on you because
they're good at it you know I mean voted
for some real bad politicians cuz
they're pros and the people who go
through life like this are professionals
so don't blame yourself for getting
taking advantage of because they're good
at it you know it's what they do do you
think so there's one person in
particular I don't even know if they
were
aware like cuz I would say that's not
true like I know that and once I figured
out what was going on I was like okay
that's not true that's not what happened
that this entire framework of like is
wrong and they didn't I don't know if it
was like
manipulation but it seemed so deeply
entrenched that they were believing it
so it was harder to pick up on because
you want you know normally when you when
I lie which I really try not to do I am
acutely aware that I'm lying and it's
like it's for a purpose especially when
I was a teenager it' be like oh I did
something bad I don't want to get in
trouble and I'm going to lie about it
very like top level surface level lies
and this kind of manipulation of reality
that I'm talking about it feels like
that person believes what they're saying
yeah you're a ter you're GNA be a
terrible narcissist feeling guilty lying
to people like that but yeah um yeah no
um I know exactly what you're talking
about I I'm like trying to think if we
have some great research on this and we
don't because I think this is deep stuff
I know in a lot of The evolutionary work
they talk about line that if you believe
it yourself you're more effective at it
yeah and you almost get the sense of
there's this sort of confabulation like
people are just making up reality and
they're like I'm just G to go with this
reality and if it doesn't work I'll just
drop it and go with another one um there
was a movie called regarding Henry back
in the day and I can't even remember who
was in it but I just remember that a
great character like that who was kind
of a mimic and would just sort of
embrace these roles um very
narcissistic so I I think that I know
that is a thing cu I've experienced it
and I do get the sense like you that
there
is people it's almost like they just put
on this outfit like it's real but you
also see where they'll cast it off and
just grab another one you're lying ah
okay well this is what happened well
dude that's a lie too yeah like what you
don't even know what the
reality is well that's not how I operate
I just put on an act and then when I get
my needs met I put on another act and
I'm just going real fast making this all
work and when you see
people so when I when I you know people
always like how do you tell who's a
narcissist who's a bad person um it's
very hard to know directly so like I'm
talking to somebody I especially in a
short communication it's hard to know if
I meet somebody really narcissistic I
usually walk away going I really like
that person yeah um so what you need to
do is you need to either look at their
history of
relationships or they so what you'll see
with somebody like you're talking about
is you're going to see train wreckage
through their life you're going to see
damage you're going to see lost
relationships bad broken business deals
dishonesty maybe criminality if you're
dealing with some real
impulsivity you'll see a train wreck
they did not get through life killing it
up to that point they might hide it but
it will be there um so always like in
relationships in particular like see a
history of that person look at how they
relate to their parents you know the
whole thing and then um the other thing
is look at how they treat people they're
not interested in so you know maybe
somebody's you know you're a high status
person so maybe he's really interested
in you but they go how are they treating
the weight staff up here how are they
treating the how do they treat the how
do they treat the bellhop at the hotel
how do they treat other people and what
you'll see is people who are
narcissistic they you know it's harder
for them to sort of treat people who are
below below them in quotes on the social
hierarchy treat them like humans you
know because it's a status thing and
they think they're better so sometimes
you can see it that way you can see
flashes of meanness or things but it's
real hard to tell I think yeah it's so
creepy I had no I like until I met a
couple of people that I was like oh wow
you don't you're not even the same world
as me uh I had no idea that even existed
couldn't fathom how that existed it's
really like the human brain is so
complicated it's crazy and I just like
I'm just the old older I get the more I
learn how complicated like belief
systems are and reality and oh I've been
doing this a long time I don't really
understand the Human Condition and I've
really tried um I also think and we
don't have great data for this when I
hear stories like that I Al often wonder
about early trauma yeah you know because
because trauma is something that doesn't
turn you into a narcissist because it
but but it does because it trauma can go
all sorts of ways like it can make you
depressed it's it's but it's associated
with all sorts of negative psychological
outcomes sexual abuse emotional abuse
physical abuse all those kind of things
other you know being in a war zone when
you're kid whatever uh losing a parent
uh you know having an alcoholic father
all those kind of things can lead to
trauma and and people trying to trying
to build a life to to kind of not have
to go through that again
and again it's not specific to
narcissism but I think when you see
people where there's a break in their
personality that can be something that
to at least look at as maybe a source
for
it that makes it like sad right because
a couple of these people I met that
Twisted reality and I was like you're
just every sentence you say there's a
lie in it it's bad um had really
difficult things happened to them really
early on and so when they go back and
say well this is what my life looked
like and you see all these train racks
but you're like oh but this really these
really terrible things happened and that
kind of is what H like what made the
train wrecks so then if you're a
forgiving person that's dangerous I feel
like just avoidance is a is better I I
think it's in terms of if it were my dad
I'm talking to I'm like be avoidant you
know just stay away it's not worth the
you know people have to go through stuff
on the other hand I think it's useful to
have compassion for people even when
sometimes they're kind of bad people
because you see there's a source to this
and they were at one point a victim and
I think yeah and you know like I said
we're all good and bad we all can be bad
people we not might not think we're
being bad I I could uh you know yell I I
there's I I guarantee you there is
something I stressed or yelled at my
daughters about for five or 10 years
that I thought I was helping them be
better people and really what it was was
my own fear about the future or
something from my childhood that I was
projecting out to them in an effort to
save them from my past that wasn't their
issue and I was doing it out of what I
thought was love but it was really out
of fear I don't know what this is
because I but I because of I discovered
I'm not doing I guarantee I did that and
I don't think that's
uncommon because the more I learn about
myself and my own kind of issues the
more I realize my best stance with my
kids is just to be loving like
everything else is kind of nonsense like
if I can be loving and be present
everything else takes care of itself but
you know especially when I was younger I
was trying to I got to get them this way
I got to get them this way I gotta put
in coming from a good place but also
coming from
Fear so I think that having compassion
for people is is useful at some point
yeah some point in your
journey and I I think like dad taught me
that too is you're going to get screwed
over by people people are going to do
terrible things to you and that can't
like warp your view of people and I'm
concerned at least at at this point I'm
pretty I'm a little bit warped in my
view of people I'm like hey just don't
like my go-to isn't trust anymore it's
distrust until I trust and I think
that's cuz I had really terrible
boundaries for a long time where I was
just like everybody's good trust
everyone and then I got hit really hard
a number of times it was like oh so I've
just gone into the into the other
direction but like compassion with
actual boundaries is somewhere where you
want to end up yeah I one I again I
don't give advice but um except to my
kids uh and even then I'm tenuous about
it but my one thing to consider in
relationships is to go slow you know if
you're if you're stepping into relate
just take your time because if when you
when I hear about people kind of get hit
by really narcissistic or
Psychopathic uh
Partners uh often it's a very you know
they they'll say love bombing in the
common parland but often it's very quick
it's very dramatic it's very emotional
um and I just say go slow
just just go slow and let and get to
know the person well you know and and
that's hard to do with high energy
narcissistic people sometimes so yeah
don't trust you know trust but verify or
you know don't trust until it's earned I
think is really smart especially in this
modern world where we're running into
people we've never known that we meet
online like ah cool I like everybody
yeah and uh there's always sh you know
there's always sharks in the in the
dolphin
pod that's I don't know what kind of
metaphor that was I was just trying make
sharks in the dolphin pod that might be
my I never had a podcast but I did it
might be called sharks in the dolphin
pod you know what that's great I I could
stand behind that I've got I've got a
whole bunch of questions we didn't get
to because we went off on so many
tangents but the tangents were better
than the question so it's responsibility
for that Michel it's 100% me no no you
don't get full responsibility for that
um yeah yeah it's helpful that's been
very helpful to me it also gives you a
feeling like I said I like the feeling
of control if you take responsibility
for everything it does stabilize you
then there aren't these external factors
that like oh that might wreck my life
that might wreck my life this is
wrecking my life it's like no it's all
you like oh okay and then I and I also
don't get jealous at people because I
look I look at people's success and what
I see is hard work and I go yeah I can
be that successful too I just got to
sacrifice these three things and I'm not
willing to do it but God bless that
person who did I respect them for
that yeah just makes it better right
that that it does make make it better
you just walk around jealous and
resentful miserable resentful you guys
are crushing it I'm just a loser yeah
yeah respect people for doing it I the
reason I'm not there is because I chose
not to I might not think that but that's
what happened it's up to me yeah or
maybe you chose other things too right
like people also look at look at people
who have tons of money and and all this
and what exactly did they have to lose
in order to get there they didn't just
end up there they either like worked
flat out maybe their relationship suffed
maybe they don't have kids maybe they
don't spend any time with their kids
like it's not just Yachts it's there's
very often a price that you do not see
for what people have that looks really
exciting yeah world's complicated very
yeah
um so what is it that that narcissistic
people want what are their goals what
are they looking for um that so the
simple answer to that is sex status and
stuff that's kind of how I just
shorthand it in my own mind but but the
primary goal with I'll say the primary
goal would be something like social
status and esteem or attent you know
attention seeking or maybe in the
clinical they'd say admiration ego needs
so you're looking for something and a
lot of times that's associated with
status so when I say sex status and
stuff that's kind of how it spills out
it's I want multiple sexual partners
attractive sexual partners arm candy
because Ian this is my dissertation it's
basically like I want somebody who's a
high value mate so that it makes me look
good I don't care about the emotional
stuff as much I care more about status
um and with status it's going to be I
want to be a leader I want to be a
celebrity so people who want to be
celebrities or want to be leaders public
speakers tend to be more
narcissistic this I mean I this is me so
I you know it's not a a slam um you know
you do research on Church they did a
study on churches in Canada and more
narcissistic pastors or priests had
longer larger congregation larger
congregations so it that's that status
piece
and then stuff it's material Goods that
convey social status these are designer
handbags you know designer watches
watches fancy cars I love watches too
but they're their status thing and uh
you know fancy car I'm looking at my
minivan out there which is sort of an
anti-status minivan um so people will
buy material Goods once they own those
those kind of become part of yourself we
call it the material self and then you
can get ego needs me hey Keith I love
your new car I'm awesome so that's kind
of how they do it they're regulating for
status via and What's creepy about that
since that's where we're going is
because the goal is ego you can swap
those things out meaning I could trade a
new girlfriend for a new Porsche and
they do the same thing for me they're
substitutable right like if somebody
like I have a great girlfriend and
somebody's like dude I'll trade you her
for a Porsche and you're like does does
the fin go up when I hit 70 like yeah
one of those I'm like dude I'll
trade how's that make you feel to be in
a relationship with somebody like that
what the hell I'm a
product I'm I thought I was a person you
mean I'm a good that makes you feel good
and you would trade me for a Porsche
just because the back went up at 70
miles an
hour H how how do you yeah that that's
not good how do you tell cuz like I like
I know throughout my life I'm definitely
more attractive to extroverts than
introverts I'm extroverted I want
someone else who's enthused about
everything to maybe a ridiculous degree
um and so I'm sure women are attracted
to these and I like I like people who
are disagreeable too I like I feel like
and this could be wrong I feel like
they're less likely to lie to spare my
feelings which I I don't like when
people do that so but what what what do
you think about narcissists and lying
like if they're high in conscientious
does that kind of hinder that because
they don't care if they hurt your
feelings or do they are they prone to
lying they're they're prone to lying but
I'm trying to think of like a l i did a
big I really did this big diary study I
can remember the stacks of paper in my
office 15 years ago and we looked at it
I don't think we published a lot on it I
did do one chapter with a student
looking at honesty and
narcissism and it I think it does
predict dishonesty but I think it's
primarily going to be in self and sort
of self-enhancing ways
so uh it might predict cheating if it's
a way to get ahead so cheating on a test
to get ahead making up data so I get
attention for a paper line about My
Success so people think I'm a big deal
so it might be lies that are directed
toward those things you're also more
likely to lie if you care about yourself
more than others you're more likely to
lie about them but here's where it gets
complicated which you mentioned the
agreeableness
pieces uh really nice people will lie
all the time when you start collecting
lie data and when you look at it they go
well those are white lies what does that
mean well I didn't want to hurt your
feelings so Michael when I told you all
that stuff when you said I really want
to know how my talk went and I said it
was great even though it wasn't I just
didn't want to hurt your feelings and
you're like I love you and so I wanted
you to hurt my feelings so my feelings
didn't get hurt in front of the live
audience yeah but the person cared too
much they couldn't do it so there's a
lot of dishonesty which if you get a guy
who's kind like I can I've dialed this
back a whole lot because I've lived in
the South a long time and softened it I
I was in a I'll just tell the story I
was in meeting with a faculty member and
he walks in I'm like well did I guess
you're not a rising star you're not a
superstar but you're doing pretty well
and I thought I I was just being honest
oh my God it I mean he was telling
people about it five years
later I'm like oh my God never doing
that again with the Millennials you know
and so that's funny I mean but but it
was and I felt really bad because that's
terrible leadership I was just kind of
be myself I should have kind of Pumped
him up and said you're yeah man you're
crushing it you're doing great you know
here's what I think would make you a
superstar and I could have framed it
like you're almost there and here's but
I was like well you're not a superstar
and I was thinking well but here's how
we get there uh yeah my point is that
when you say I look for people who are
kind of jerks and extroverted because
they'll tell me the truth you're
probably right because they probably
will sometimes but they'll also probably
manipulate you too because that's if
they're more narcissistic perfect so
what you're what you're saying is like
you're saying I'm
selecting uh for a kind of a a
cross-section of traits and in that
cross-section of people with those
traits are going to be a lot more
narcissism than their average population
it's like saying hey where do you want
to meet somebody at at a nightclub or a
bar or do you want to meet them you know
at a I don't know Emoji conference or
something I don't know what the
introverts do and you go I like I like
meeting people at I like meeting people
at bars they're going to be great let
get me more narcissism you know that's
just how it is because you're selecting
and that's you're just getting more in
that
sample but but I get it because you know
you like what you like you want somebody
with some energy but also who's Loving
You so narcissism isn't all bad it's
like like I was saying if you think
about in big five high extroversion high
agency High
assertiveness plus low agreeable well if
you took that person the the
extroversion side it's really good
that's what you fell in love with to
tell you the truth or that's what you
liked initially and the agreeableness
you go man if they were just nice it
would be perfect you know if they were
really EXT but also a little
nicer um so half of narcissism's
attractive and the other half is not
attractive and and so we end up with
these
Rel there's a they use a lot of
narcissistic characters in movies and
there's this one Doctor Strange have you
ever seen that movie he's like a Marvel
character yeah inappropriately young my
dad bought all the that's C kubric
right oh I don't I was thinking no oh
that's Doctor Strange Love of course
your dad did that because that's that's
actually actual literary content with
Slim picking drive you know going yeeha
on the bomb out of that was deep parody
and Peter sers no this is garbage modern
entertainment for the children and so
it's a Marvel character who's Doctor
Strange like oh of course Dr str's Like
a Surgeon right so he's a he's a classic
super narcissistic character that's his
whole character he's narcissistic he's a
surgeon his hands break so he can't do
his surgery and because his entire value
is wrapped around being a great surgeon
he's lost and he can't just say dude I'm
going to start writing books and be a
teacher and all my friends he can't do
that because it's all ego and then
that's what breaks him um and then he
goes to that spiritual transformation
but but he's a classic narcissist I mean
freaking surgeon like what's more
narcissistic that you think of than a
surgeon and and by the way there's a
reason surgeons are narcissistic because
they kill people I mean like how Budd is
a neurosurgeon goes you know you kill
people he goes you don't think about it
when it's a high-risk surgery people
will die on your operating table very
rarely but if if you care so much that's
going to ruin your career you can't be a
surgeon so you got to be a little
callous to do the job man because you
got the next patient you know you do it
100% you work as hard as you can you
feel terrible but only for a night and
the next day you feel
good um what are the what are the main
professions of people who are
narcissists
that's a a really good question so if
you imagine your somebody is
narcissistic so grandiose I want
positive attention and status from
people what I like is people looking up
at me and thinking I'm a big deal well
where can I get
that
podcaster I I will talk about podcaster
in a minute if you want because I think
it's a little more complicated but yeah
entertainment I want to be famous
because if I'm famous then people say
hey Keith I saw you on the Peterson show
you're famous I go oh I love being
famous thanks um or I will be a leader
so I will become a leader of a company
the leader in the military a leader of a
church because leadership is a way I can
get status so I'll try to be a
politician I'll try to do something
where I get status so Entertainer uh
status Seeker I'll try to get power over
people so I'll try to find some
opportunity to control people so at
least I have that kind of deep power
that's probably politics law maybe and
um another place you see it is uh in the
medical field again you see it
insurgence this a big study out of the
UK and British narcissism is lower than
in the US in
general but the higher narcissism scores
were with the surgeons versus like
General
Practitioners ah yeah makes sense
fighter pilots versus ground crew you
know that the original astronauts the
Chuck Jagger the Buzz Aldren those guys
were kind of narcissistic that was their
profile Risk Takers and like I say
and the original astronauts were
narcissist
narcissistic uh the new astronauts I say
are Canadian they're very nice and the
reason for that is they because they're
all there's six of them in a tube
together and floating around the world
if you put six narcissist and if you put
Chuck and Buzz and all those guys in the
tube they'd start breaking stuff they'd
be like this mission is ours they'd
fight over leadership then one of them
be like we're going to Mars screw those
idiots on Earth you know that they're
problems you know these Mavericks are
problems so you find narcissists trying
to get attention where they can you know
trying to get places they can get status
esteem Etc your podcaster comment was
great because I do I've done a lot a
podcast and usually in a podcast you end
up chatting with somebody for an hour or
two and it turns into kind of a real
conversation sometimes you talk off air
for half an hour afterwards yeah
sometimes you end up becoming buddies
with people and if you're a podcaster
you can't you can't fake it you have to
be authentic or it's not going to
work meaning so it's like Joe Rogan's a
nice guy just oh yeah he's a nice dude
and if you were narcissist and was a
fake bser that would have come out you
know I talked to the guy would have come
out in the first 30 minutes I would have
figured that out but when you do old
school
television you know you go in there and
you do a piece like you jump on there
you got two minutes to say something
clever and everybody looks good you know
so if you do old television like the
celebrities are there sitting there and
then the people R out and do the puff up
their so you got the Shine off them and
then they do their fake smile and you do
your five minute stick and they're gone
you can be really narcissistic and do
that job I mean that that's perfect for
narcissists so I think in the when they
um Dr Drew from the show love lines and
a guy named Mark Young who's a he's a
real good dude he's an accounting
professor at USC really nice guy and uh
they were interested in Celebrity
narcissism which is a really interesting
con concept or question and no one can
get date on celebrities so what they did
was before all the love line shows mark
would show up in the Green Room which is
where I'm I'm saying this for your
audience I'm sorry but the Green Room is
where you kind of hang out before going
on a show and so he'd hang out in the
green room chat with the celebrities and
he give him a a version of the
narcissistic personality inventory in a
couple questions have them fill it out
not put their name on it so it was
totally Anonymous like so because no one
that's the only reason way these people
would do it is if there's no way to
trace it put in a big bag so we could
never find
out and but when they went through the
data it was fascinating because the
highest scores for narcissism the
celebrities were the reality television
stars and the and the second highest
were standup comedy then it went to
actors and the bottom were musicians so
when you think about it and you kind of
interpret this who knows it's one study
but people who want to go on reality
television generally being famous for
being famous I uh you know I chatted
with Chris Williamson about that who you
you must know Chris but he's you know
he's on that love Island show and yeah
that was really interesting because he's
not like that at all but he has such
great insight into it but he's like yeah
that's pretty much it just shallow and
narcissistic not much more to it um
standup comedy you got to be narcissist
be narcissistic because you stand in
front of a room of a thousand people who
are going to mock you and Heckle you and
you got to go to war with them it's like
being a professor but they don't they're
kind of drunk and up for a good time so
it's harder if you like it be like me
teaching but the students were wasted
and were and if they heckled me nothing
would happen so you it's it's it's fun
but it's more of a
contest and what happens with musicians
is if you're too narcissistic you can't
play in a group so I talked because I'm
in Athens Georgia yeah Athens Georgia is
is kind of a music music town so we're
the home of the b52s and RM and
Widespread Panic a lot of these kind of
old groups came out of here and there's
a lot of musicians so I talked to him
about it and they laughed and they said
oh yeah that's what we call like lead
singer syndrome you know so sometimes
and he goes they go yeah in Athens when
that happens we just send you to
Nashville so oh that's funny so they're
using social control that if a musician
gets too big of an ego they can't play
with different groups they can't be
humble they is like we'll send them to
Natural with the other egomaniacs and
they can kind of do their thing there so
I I think there's you know the way we
set up Fame some is some is more
conducive to being narcissistic or being
a diva and some some is suppresses that
more yeah I had a couple questions about
social media because I think you've done
some social media and narcissism
research uh and so yeah I wanted to get
your your input on self selfies and
Instagram and narcissism and then I had
a question that I want to ask uh before
I forget it but I what I assume is
people who are more prone to take
selfies are more prone to n being
narcissistic is is that accurate uh
since we yeah so when we when we looked
at the data it's it's a little more it's
a little Nuance um people who are more
narcissistic are more comfortable taking
and sharing selfies oh comfortable
comfortable boom do it share it uh with
grandiose narcissism and they're more
likely to share selfies but it's a
certain kind of selfie so with
narcissist you're more likely to see uh
full body you're more likely to see uh
more skin and it's more likely to be a
true selfie whereas people who are
agreeable will take a lot of selfies but
they're often with other people you know
so they like capture a picture with
their friends and send it to their
friend
and that is something that's more
associated with some trade
agreeableness so the selfie itself can
have a little different connotation to
it and people who are more vulnerable in
the narcissistic so sort of narcissistic
but with a lot of neuroticism this
they'll do selfies but it's really hard
so they'll do a selfie and they'll
struggle with it because they're like
it's important for them to get good
feedback but they're not really sure so
it's so I talked to a couple influencers
I talked to one reporter who did a uh
some in-depth reporting when people used
to do that on social media influencers
and what it sounds like to me is that
that life can be really it can be very
challenging because what we see is
somebody confidently putting out one
snapshot in Dubai or whever they do
selfies I guess Dubai and the beach and
what's behind the
scenes is um a lot of stress and and a
lot of taking five or 15 shots and maybe
going through 100 shots trying to get
the right one and then putting out there
and hoping the world thinks they're a
legend does that make sense so with
vulnerable
narcissism
um it is even um it's really hard to
take selfies but they still do it but
it's work so in general narcissism more
selfies but more individual more body
and again it's more about status and
look good versus looking about being
like you're closer connected with people
that makes
sense I don't think I like taking
selfies I I hate it so much the first
one I had to do I had I had to fake it
how did you Fake it Well it's like a
journalist just like I did a paper it's
like we want a picture of you with the
selfie and I'm like dude I feel like an
idiot he's like I just put your arm out
and I'll just take a picture so I just
held my arm out and he took a picture so
it look like a selfie it it does though
grow social media platforms which grows
an audience which allows you to grow a
business so what happens then um social
media when they built
it I I look at it this way it's like
social media runs on ego not all ego it
can also run on cat humor and anger but
what makes people want to post and share
well it's ego that's a big part of the
network so the people that are the
people who have more followers online
are more narcissistic the people who
post more selfies are more
narcissistic um and that's and so what
that means is when I go on Twitter or
Instagram when I look at all the people
I'm going to see a world that's over
represented or oversaturated with
narcissism because the people putting
out all the context so my network from
the other side I'm GNA say God this is a
narcissistic
World um it's not it's over represented
in terms of who's posting online but
what you're running into is the absolute
problem is we all need to have a social
media presence if you want to build a
brand and get money so you can feed your
children and pay your mortgage so you
have to do it and people struggle with
this if it's not natural to them so if
you know like I'm not on Twitter because
I I I love to talk to people but like on
Twitter I hate all the angry stuff and I
just I'm just kind of like I want to
have a discussion without fighting in
politics so I I like I start a stub
stack but I can't even write it because
I'm like ah everyone's going to get
pissed off who needs that nonsense um
but it sucks for my brand so what I
should do is suck it up and do it or I
should hire somebody that be my ego to
go out there and promote me and in the
media world that's called a publicist so
you would hire a publicist and go do
publicity and that would be a way to
professionalize it um
but the truth is that if you have an ego
or a comfortable
self-promoting it's a real advantage in
the intellectual world just to get your
ideas out there and it didn't used to be
that way but now it kind of is and so
interesting landscape is yeah you kind
of got just suck it up and go for it oh
totally yeah oh dude my favorite AC I
mean who was an adviser my my favorite
academic was a guy named enco who was
kind of on the Spectrum which was rare
for a guy born in the 30s he'd wear like
blue he'd what would he wear light blue
pants a blue blazer and and new Balan
blue tennis shoes every day same outfit
and couldn't really talk to people but
God he was smart knew he was a he was
like one of the first great attitudes
researchers one of the greatest
conversations in my life with him was in
the bathroom uncomfortably at the urinal
because he didn't understand social
relationships explaining why pavlovian
conditioning and two value logic and
haider's Balan theory of interpersonal
attraction were all the same model
fundamentally great conversation in the
bathroom urinal with this guy who didn't
know how to relate to people he never
made he never would make it in the
modern world because he's not a
self-promoter but nowadays you kind of
got to do it the problem is we select
for self-promoters it hurts science or
it hurts other things because we're
pulling so much for self-promotion
missing skill so that's yeah it's it's
just a tough world it's just the nature
of it
but yeah you you kind of have to train
yourself to do this stuff I'm very
comfortable with podcast because it
feels like authentic conversation I'm
not comfortable going out there and
saying oh I'm a legend I mean [__]
that's probably good though it's good I
don't most people yeah yeah I don't even
think most people the the crazy thing is
that marketing does actually seem to to
work like I was talking to a contractor
the other day who said he was buying uh
these classes online that taught you how
to like get rich quick using uh Drop
Shipping and stuff like that and I know
that there are people online who've made
money that way but he certainly hasn't
he spent a lot of money that way and I
was like don't those kind of scream I
was like you have to be careful cuz some
of those kind of scream scam no
apparently doesn't yeah like apparently
doesn't scream scam to everybody even if
some look at it you're like well that's
definitely not real I I notice uh I'm
always curious about people selling
courses about how to get rich you always
wonder if you knew how to get rich why
are you selling courses why aren't you
in Maui I shouldn't say Maui I guess
because they yeah but you know what I
mean Fiji right
now yeah yeah yeah and then how did you
get riched did you get riched by selling
courses and is that what you're teaching
people to do some of those courses teach
you to sell
courses like a course on course selling
kind of Meta Meta course I don't know
I've had people say sell a course I'm
like dude I you know I think I've done
courses for people it's cool I just like
I couldn't do it myself because I I kind
of I gotta get my self-esteem up that's
what I need to work on my self-esteem
then I can sell a course self you'd sell
a great course what no no I'm all in
favor of you no I know I no it's just
when I like people like oh do a course
online I'm like man I can't even tweet
you know I just it's hard for me to do
all that like I just like it you know
it's good to have a publist and stuff
because self- promotion's hard I mean
even and I got a big personality it's
not like I have any problem with the
extra version piece I just was raised
that if you're like promoting yourself
you're kind of a
loser talking about students
today um talking about vulnerable
narcissism and there was a school
shooter in Santa Barbara back in the day
and there's been so many of these now
but one of the things he wrote in his
Manifesto was I'm going to go shoot
people because I'm going to shoot I'm
going to show them who the real Alpha
Male is
now and I said you know I said if you're
hanging out with a bunch of guys and
somebody calls themselves an alpha male
I can tell you one thing they're not an
alpha manale that's all I can tell you
because if you if you just hang around
with high status man no one does that
stuff if a guy it's loser material guys
are quiet and uh you you hang around
with people incredibly accomplished you
will never know because they won't say a
thing one of their buddies like oh you
know my buddy um people don't say that
because that's just that's just gross
it's just not what I mean I I speaking
for men just men don't do that
successful men don't do that that's kind
of what boys do not even boys boys are
cool no one does that it's
narcissistic um so that self-promotion
comes hard for a lot of people yeah yeah
I that's probably why like now so at the
beginning when I was growing my uh
Instagram it was pretty painful like
everything you do is painful every bit
of content is painful and so the more I
did it the the less painful it got cuz I
was like oh well the repercussions to
posting something I don't think is
perfect aren't that high no one really
cares as much as you care but uh I have
somebody else doing social media so I
don't have to do it so then
solves that problem right but what you
did was you outsourced that to somebody
else which is the best thing to do it's
still your content I mean they can just
take your content and they can do the
promotion stuff and they can deal with
the people online
and you don't have to just you don't
have to put yourself through that all
the time I I find it very difficult but
some people are very natural with it and
that's really positive and no you know
people are different I just do the fun
stuff that's like replying to comments
and things and some sometimes posting
the odd selfie but like I've managed to
Outsource just constant content uploads
which is and then and then you don't
have to be on it all the time like a job
yeah then then you have yeah Outsourcing
a lot of this is hard and like the New
Media world where you've got to run the
whole show yourself is really hard for
people I it's a this new world is
awesome uh with social media but it's
also just kind of wild west in ways it's
it's cool I don't know
yeah well Keith that was very
interesting we went in a bunch of
directions I wasn't planning on going
that was good thank you for com on yeah
I thought that was really a fun
conversation yeah the part about
intuition that was good I like that
those are the kind of similar
conclusions I've come to that was
helpful yeah ask your dad about it
because he he knows young better than I
do I've only made it most of the way
through the red book and he's probably
read the black book too but uh but do
think that that I think that's what Yung
was really working on with with
intuition yeah I I'm going to have to
try those I've been meaning to like
delve into that a little bit more but I
I want to delve into that because that's
interesting yeah I our models of
psychology are not dumb we're pretty
sophisticated but still our
understanding of The Human Condition is
very very limited that we are there's a
lot more to do and we're a very young
science and I think sometimes people
think well if you haven't studied it
it's not real it's like no we haven't
got to it and the feds aren't you know
there's not a lot of Federal grant money
to study intuition and Vibes so it's not
like there a big big rush so you know I
think a lot there's a lot of interesting
things we're going to see over the years
come out yeah yeah um if people do want
to find you online is there a website or
anywhere people can oh um I have W Keith
campbell.com that needs to be updated
but I haven't found a person yet and uh
I'm on Twitter sometimes at w Keith
Campbell and that's about it yeah okay
well thank you for coming on oh that was
fun thanks so
[Music]
much